hello everyone hello hey
well like so many people who grew up in
the 90s i was obsessed
with the original like next level
obsessed so i want to know how cool it
is for you guys being able to continue
that legacy
kayla let's start with you oh man i
i am yeah i actually hadn't had any sort
of relationship with the film
it came out before i think we were all
born
um i'm old
no i mean i wish i was a kid in the 90s
um but
when i started telling people in my life
that were a little bit older
and had so much love for the film and
their emphatic like cult classic like
you don't know what this film means to
me
don't screw it up it like changed my
life i
there was definitely a lot of pressure
but um zoe lister jones
new upgraded version for for girls today
was um so beautiful and timely
and um it was just such an honor to
um piggyback on this um
this this film and and tell our own
version
and um and yeah continue the legacy
i love it i think what i loved about
this film too is all the girl power even
more so than the original
so how refreshing is it for you guys to
read a script where you're seeing
women supporting other women gideon
let's start with you
um i mean i love that i think what we
need more of always
and not just now but in 20 years and
forever um as women of raising each
other up and not tearing each other down
because i feel like you know growing up
in movies
at one point you always see some really
nasty fight happen between the
girlfriends or something that tears them
apart
and it just doesn't really feel like
that needed to be there and i think like
what's so important about this is like
these girls love each other so much in
this film
and would literally go to any length
to save their coven and i think that
anybody can create their own coven
anywhere and just have those close
friends and like you know for women i
think like
we just have to remember like we all
have to stand together because
we should run everything women
are we are the makers and
um you know we need to keep that energy
going and i think this movie
provides that i hope people take that
can take that with them
i love that okay now obviously it's
about a coven you guys have a lot of
power
if you had to choose one power as a
witch what would it be
love you let's start with you i think
i'm gonna go with the self
love spell oh yeah our power uh
definitely i'm in love just with
everything that is that
so that's perfect okay zoe what's up
uh for me i would definitely choose to
be able like
in the trailer we see that i kind of
give lily these uh
pearly euphoria makeup vibes i would
definitely choose to give myself like
plastic surgery like i would have like
the flick of my wrist like my lips are
re-injected
that's amazing and yeah that would take
a lot of time
and money maybe gideon what would your
power be
oh goodness
i know this is so cheesy but i just want
to be able to like
fly man like i really just want to fly
my whole life i had dreams that i could
just start like swimming in the air and
just like
walls and like go up to chat i want to
fly
i really need to that would be such a
good one
okay i would love to
snap my fingers and just have everyone
be registered
and go vote or vote early
you know just be ready and prepared you
know in studies like
the majority of young people are the
people who
don't um vote or
don't get out there and participate and
uh i would just
uh like to have a spell to change that
that's a good one um so you have a
pretty cool story
about the audition you essentially
dressed the part
before you even auditioned right are you
hearing about that yeah
yeah um okay so like i was getting ready
for dinner
and basically i have put on this outfit
and of course like i haven't really had
a close relationship with the craft
uh but i had seen it all over instagram
tumblr twitter
and so i like thrown this outfit just
unintentionally and it's
two weeks before i got the audition and
i put on this purple metallic lip and
this white button up
and this purple overall corduroy dress
and i was like i look like a craft girl
like i look like i can be a witch
and then i get the audition and i was
like
jesus that literally jesus
so yeah one thing i found through this
movie was god
[Music]
that's amazing yeah
i am out of questions you guys uh out of
time but so nice chatting with you and
as a fan of the 90s i love
this one